and then what we'll do is as you're
going into projection
you have to I want you to bring
awareness to the slipperiness
Okay the reason you lose that adhesion
the eye key is again your external you
have too much Yong in the hand
and it starts to move opposite this hand
you you can only
uh I want you to feel this so I push you
see it's very slippery very slippery but
you see how it scrap it grabbed on to
you right so as you push on to me if I
stay too much Yin you you slip you see
that but if I'm too much young I'll slip
I have to match you so as you come in I
just keep matching that you see and the
friction is increasing as we're going
right so you you're trying to push me if
I go live you see how you got slippery
but in the same way if I
over Yong you I will get slippery again
okay so you you have that feeling
okay and the more she pushes into me the
more young I have to do to match it do
you understand and the less you push
into me the less young I have to do
there's the stickiness it's still there
you see okay okay so maybe you start to
feel like you're slipping so what do you
have to do
you got to eat in more okay so you're
like oh I'm starting to throw but I'm
slipping do you see you'll start getting
more and you'll come back okay got it
now
it's always going to be like that you're
always going to raise your young Indian
levels in response to what I'm doing and
also as a reaction to what I'm doing to
you so for example you might have a
great deal of young on the initial push
do you see when you have perfect posture
but as I start to take that posture
you're going to not have as much yawn
and if I keep the initial Yong level and
I start to tilt you you're losing it on
this arm these this bottom arm down here
you see that and I keep pushing then
eventually I slip so it has to decrease
in order so that I can have the
stickiness to it's constantly changing
constantly changing
change your levels okay so usually as I
have coached a lot of people is you
smell
the throw at this young level and not
realizing her yin and young levels are
changing and that's where you start to
see that arm slit so what you want to do
instead is the feeling if I want to be
stuck here I just here at their right
arm you see if you feel it okay if I
want to be stuck here I just feel that I
don't really care about your throat
you understand
all right so uh just uh I'm gonna do the
same Journal if you're gonna give me
that arm I'm going to use that arm
and I'm paying attention to where
they're I am
sticking or slipping okay with the same
task
I'll get her you're right yes okay don't
disconnect like that
said yeah
[Music]
okay
I'm paying attention
how much slip I'm doing and then I'm
gonna try to
do the coaching tip okay